à l'Assemblée nationale ils sont entrés
dans la maison du peuple et dans
l'antichambre du pouvoir
depuis près d'un an les 88 députés du
rassemblement national forment le
premier groupe d'opposition dans
l'hémicycle
[Musique]
jamais nous ne retirons à propos jamais
nous excuserons devant le mal que vous
avez fait à la France dans les murs de
l'institution ce parti au passé
tourmenté n'a qu'une obsession gagner en
respectabilité s'imposer en alternative
crédible il s'agit d'une marche haute
que nous venons de passer vers
l'accession au pouvoir ça ouvre le champ
des possibles en fait on se dit enfin
enfin on va avoir des moyens pour
pouvoir montrer aux gens qu'on est
compétent montrer aux gens qu'on va
travailler on sent une assurance et une
détermination chez ses députés une
solidarité aussi entre eux c'est que on
va être au combat c'est un travail long
pour sortir la démarche du système
quelle est la stratégie de ce RN
ambitieux quel obstacles se dressent sur
sa route
s'entendre comprendre décider retour sur
l'année parlementaire qui a vu ce parti
s'installer à l'Assemblée nationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur LCP pour
cette grande soirée électorale
législative 2022 nous sommes le 19 juin
2022 et devenu pour le rassemblement
national une date majeure celle de son
plus grand succès électoral le parti
conquiert 89 sièges à l'Assemblée ils
étaient partis à ces modestes dans leurs
ambitions c'est
peut-être le plus spectaculaire ce soir
oui j'ai ressenti de l'émotion j'ai
versé ma larme un peu le soir quand j'ai
vu dégringoler l'intégralité des
circonscriptions qui tombaient dans
l'escarcelle du rassemblement national
des journées telles que celle là des
soirées telles que celle là c'est sûr
qu'elle marque une existence il y a un
côté 21 avril
finalement
c'est un événement politique
inattendu
douloureux pour ceux qui comme moi
veut dire croient à la République se
souvient de l'histoire longue et
coupable de l'extrême droite en France
c'est un Véro qui a sauté au plan
parlementaire et la capacité du
rassemblement national à rentrer au
Parlement à devenir majoritaire dans de
multiples circonscriptions en France
dans le cadre d'un scrutin qui jusque
alors favorisait uniquement les grands
partis ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que le Front National est devenu un
grand parti
[Musique]
89 députés 88 aujourd'hui suite à
l'invalidation d'un scrutin ce chiffre
se transforme quelques jours plus tard
en visage
félicitations
bravo
les nouveaux députés RN euphorique entre
dans la cour d'honneur
cette affaire
[Musique]
c'est bon
la photo de famille est historique à
l'Assemblée le RN va désormais jouer
dans la cour des grands
moi je sors d'un mandat ou nous étions 6
bon être si ça l'Assemblée nationale
c'est terrible c'est terriblement
frustrant et c'est accessoirement
terriblement ennuyeux parce que la
réalité c'est que vous n'avez
barre sur rien vous ne pouvez rien
changer vous ne pouvez rien imposer vous
ne pouvez rien proposer nous n'avions
pas de groupe et voir effectivement ces
88 députés
c'était là encore la promesse de pouvoir
faire
le chef de fil incontesté Marine Le Pen
a quitté un an plus tôt la présidence du
parti pour s'engager dans la campagne
présidentielle elle devient sans
surprise présidente du groupe
parlementaire RN son avenir politique
immédiat va s'inscrire à l'Assemblée
j'ai conscience que le centre de gravité
de la vie politique va se déporter et
arriver à l'Assemblée nationale ce qui
n'était pas le cas à partir du moment il
y avait une majorité absolue c'est vrai
que bon tout est un peu prévisible il
faut quand même le dire quand il y a une
majorité relative alors effectivement le
premier groupe d'opposition un rôle très
important à jouer tout de suite elle
distribue les premières consignes elle
insiste sur la nécessité de se montrer à
la hauteur de l'institution et de bien
présenter
la première réunion de groupe c'était un
discours assez long en fait de Marine Le
Pen sur la responsabilité politique en
général et le fait de se comporter
dignement respectueusement d'Honoré par
sa tenue vestimentaire pour les femmes
et les hommes le mandat qu'on nous a
donné ça s'inscrivait dans un discours
général sur la responsabilité qu'on
allait avoir pendant 5 ans aussi comme
premier groupe d'opposition il y a pas
eu de mot d'ordre on nous demande de
respecter les lieux les institutions
mais j'allais dire aucun de mes
collègues députés n'aurai envie de faire
le contraire par sa taille le groupe RN
étant position de force pour obtenir des
postes clés au bureau de l'Assemblée
notamment des vice-présidents le
règlement stipule que la répartition
doit refléter l'équilibre des forces
politiques je sens tout de suite que on
fait partie de l'équation ils peuvent
pas faire sans nous on est 89 députés ça
aurait été un tel scandale que nous
n'ayons pas de vice-présidents que j'ai
moi j'ai plus senti qu'on était
incontournable
madame Hélène Laporte 284 voies
monsieur Sébastien Chenu 290 voix le
groupe RN obtient deux postes de
vice-président sur les six que contre
l'institution
si de nombreux députés de la majorité
ont voté pour ces candidats ceux de la
nupesse si son refusés la réalité c'est
que un certain nombre de députés de la
majorité
on glissé des bulletins rassemblement
national dans l'urne au moment de la
désignation des vices précédents c'est
ça la réalité et le choix que nous
avions nous fait nous c'est de ne pas
mettre le doigt dans une forme de
banalisation je trouve ça normal j'ai
soutenu et participé à cette démarche le
fait qu'il y ait des vice-président
c'est très désagréable c'est même
parfois un sentiment de honte qu'on en
soit arrivé là d'avoir un rassemblement
national si fort mais c'est une réalité
il faut y faire face et y faire face
c'est accepter que dans l'institution à
la proportionnelle de la représentation
des députés il y ait des postes à
responsabilité pour l'ensemble des
groupes que ce soit ceux de la nuque
c'est ceux du rassemblement national
ces postes de vice-présidents ont
surtout une valeur symbolique il ne
confère pas de pouvoir supplémentaires
mais permettent au RN d’assoire sa
présence à l'assemblée Hélène Laporte et
Sébastien Chenu préside certaines
séances depuis le prestigieux perchoir
c'est très important parce que quand on
a un homme et une femme
issue du rassemblement national qui en
tant que vice-président peuvent être à
la place de la présidence et organiser
les débats démocratiques ça montre que
peu à peu cet homme et cette femme ont
suffisamment intégré les éléments de la
culture du pluralisme démocratique
qu'ils peuvent maintenant les faire
vivre nous faisons partie du bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale donc à ce titre
nous nous réunissons toutes les semaines
lors de la conférence des présidents on
a également une affectation de
délégation moi j'ai la délégation des du
patrimoine de l'Assemblée nationale donc
dans ce cas là je donne mon avis sur
l'entrée ou la sortie de telle ou tel
tableau sculpture vase oeuvre d'art en
général en plus de ces deux postes le RN
préside plusieurs groupes d'amitié et
d'études dont le plus important consacré
à la filière viticole avec la députée
Stéphanie Galzi
en
raison de tous
mes chers collègues Jean-Philippe Tanguy
préside également une commission
d'enquête sur les ingérences étrangères
qui a auditionné plusieurs anciens
ministres
peu à peu le RN tisse ainsi à toi à
l'Assemblée au point de ce fondre
presque naturellement dans le décor
mais cette entreprise de normalisation
se heurte à un mur
[Musique]
après le Front républicain pour la
grande majorité des autres députés le RN
restent imparti
différent pendant des mois pendant des
semaines vous nous avez fait croire vous
avez voulu nous faire oublier qui vous
étiez réellement vos beaux mots vos
cravates ne nous ont jamais trompé vous
étiez vous êtes vous resterez un
mouvement d'extrême droite
qui agit comme la chauve-souris de la
fable dans le parti des oiseaux elle
montre ses ailes dans le parti des
fachos elle montre son poil et elle
atteint un rat
c'est pas un parti comme les autres il
est l'héritier de d'une histoire longue
de Dreyfus
à nos jours et on n'oublie pas ce que
furent les mots par exemple de
Jean-Marie Le Pen dans le programme du
Front national moi-même je ne serai pas
perçu comme français puisque je suis pas
né ici mes enfants qui sont dans la mer
n'est pas né ici serait pas tout à fait
français non plus c'est-à-dire eux ils
ont des catégories de français ça c'est
profondément destructeur donc c'est un
c'est un mouvement qui qui n'accepte pas
l'idée nationale au sens civique des
lumières c'est pour ça que c'est
différent que c'est dangereux le passé
du RN et son positionnement idéologiques
en font un parti plus scruté que tous
les autres le 3 novembre une séance de
questions au gouvernement va brutalement
le rappeler la parole est à Monsieur
Carlos Martens bilongo pour le groupe la
France insoumise il est en 34 rescapés
secouru par l'océan de Vik Ings sont
bloqués sur le pont du bateau depuis 11
jours depuis 11 jours ils attendent de
pouvoir débarquer dans un port sûr les
personnes secourues se trouvent dans une
situation d'urgence absolue des
prévisions météo indiquent une
détérioration significative du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel est le député qui vient de
prononcer cette phrase pardon
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite je suis allé voir Grégoire
de Fournas pour lui demander si le sens
de sa phrase était bien de désigner le
bateau je lui ai fait jurer sur ses
enfants
le fait qu'il met jurait ça j'ai
considéré que je devais que je pouvais
le défendre de bonne foi tout de suite
Grégoire et Jean-Philippe Tanguy
descendent dire à elle mais attendez pas
du tout il y a un malentendu tout de
suite et en fait le tumulte j'allais
dire prends de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle il y a mon avis il voit une
fenêtre de tir extraordinaire en disant
alors là ça y est essaie de nous faire
passer pour ce que nous ne sommes pas je
crois que ça a été la piqûre de rappel
pour tout celles et ceux qui peut-être
avaient avaient un peu baiser la garde
ils ont xénophobes sont racistes voilà
c'est la réalité
ça a été un couac parce qu'on avait
l'impression d'un retour du refoulé il y
avait un nouveau un dérapage un député
un peu sanguin qui en effet revenait sur
le terrain
de la xénophobie des idées simples et
simples listes
malgré ses efforts pour se notabiliser
le RN reste un parti très isolé à
l'Assemblée aucune alliance ne semble
possible avec les autres groupes pire
ces propositions de loi et amendements
subissent un rejet quasi systématique
les chiffres sont éloquents au 16 mai
sur les 1497 amendements des députés RN
discutés en séance publique 40 seulement
ont été adoptés c'est le chiffre le plus
faible de tous les groupes
parlementaires
c'est nos adversaires qui refusent de
voter les éléments de bon sens qu'on
défend c'est complètement absurde quand
vous avez la nuit pèse qui refuse par
exemple de voter la suppression de la
TVA sur les produits de première
nécessité alors que c'est dans le
programme au moins du PS c'est eux qui
sont ridicules c'est pas nous cette
situation et scandaleuse parce que et
elle démontre elle est très révélatrice
parce qu'elle demande quand elle était
le seul groupe que le pouvoir dans
toutes ses facettes
craint parce qu'il représente
l'alternance c'est le groupe du
Rassemblement national qu'on n'a pas été
élu pour voter les propositions du
rassemblement du rassemblement national
j'allais dire c'est pas quelque chose de
très pensé c'est d'une certaine manière
dans notre façon d'être face à cette
forme de cordon sanitaire les élurnes
ont choisi la stratégie inverse heure
revendique une ligne politique
d'ouverture
et un des enjeux de notre groupe c'était
de montrer qu'on était pas sectaire et
que quand un amendement arrivé sur la
table on regardait pas d'où il venait on
regardait s'il améliorait ou pas
quotidien on n'est pas élu pour se faire
plaisir dès l'instant nous avons un
texte qui nous semble en adéquation avec
notre programme et avec l'intérêt
national on va le voter quel que soit la
couleur politique
votez les amendements ou les textes des
autres c'est aussi le chemin le plus
court pour le RN quand il veut peser sur
les travaux parlementaires le groupe a
ainsi voté les projets de loi du
gouvernement sur le pouvoir d'achat la
sécurité ou le nucléaire
la loi sur le nucléaire on l'a voté
alors que c'est franchement on trouve
que c'est pas la hauteur mais c'est pas
on va pas faire la politique du pire on
a voté la prime pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est pas la mesure qu'on aurait voulu
voir est-ce que ça peut servir quelques
Français oui donc même si c'est pas
parfait on le vote je ne me réjouirai
jamais que le rassemblement national
vote l'un de nos textes parce que quand
on a une majorité relative on doit avoir
l'humilité de reconnaître que on a
besoin de partenaires politiques pour
voter des textes mais moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on est des
partenariats avec avec des parties qui
ne sont pas à l'extrême droite ni à
l'extrême gauche d'ailleurs j'ai une
solution cette ouverture dans les votes
s'accompagne d'une attitude mesurée en
séance se comporter en député modèle
pour casser l'image historique du parti
mais aussi pour se démarquer d'une autre
opposition il y a une concurrence bien
sûr entre le rassemblement national et
les filles et ils ont vu très vite que
et les filles avaient choisi
stratégie de la perturbation de la vie
parlementaire et là le rassemblement
national a décidé de se poser en
s'opposant à cette stratégie ils ont
plus à gagner qu'à perdre à cette
stratégie du bon élève ce contraste avec
la France insoumise apparaît au grand
jour lors de l'examen du texte majeur de
l'année parlementaire la réforme des
retraites les deux groupes pis sont
opposés mais dans les débats les députés
RN se montrent très discrets en
comparaison avec leur rivaux
dans la réforme des retraites je ne les
ai entendus ni dans l'hémicycle ni dans
la rue
et donc la question c'est véritable à
quoi
servent-ils il n'avait rien
d'intelligent à dire très peu
d'amendements à proposer ils n'ont fait
que de ronger leurs freins et compter
sur un peu le soutien macroniste de ce
discours qui était contre l'obstruction
insoumise etc bon la forme c'est pas du
tout caché dans le débat je veux dire on
va pas qu'est-ce que on va pas se rouler
par terre on va pas prendre le micro et
hurler ça n'a aucun intérêt donc on
s'est exprimé quand on devait le faire
on s'est exprimé dans les médias là où
la France insoumise dépose près de 13000
amendements le RN en rédige un peu plus
de 200 symboles de deux approches
totalement opposées
moi j'ai toujours été persuadé qu'il y
avait une opposition majoritaire à la
réforme des retraites au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale donc je voulais
qu'on aille au vote et je voulais au
moins qu'on aille jusqu'à cet article 7
qui était donc le report de l'âge de
départ à la retraite et on en a été
empêché en fait par la stratégie
totalement stupide de la nupes sur
l'ensemble de l'année parlementaire le
bilan du groupe RN apparaît contrasté
comme encore en rodage
c'est un bilan parlementaire
d'installation en fait c'est l'ennemi
qui Tapie discret
this sa toile au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale ils sont plutôt une stratégie
de spectateur de spectateurs engagés
mais de spectateurs et là il faut qu'il
fasse attention ils ont encore tout un
travail d'opinion à faire sur leur
capacité à incarner une grande force de
gouvernement de proposition et là le bât
blesse
l'année parlementaire du RN ne se limite
pas au travail législatif et au débat
parisien
elle se mesure aussi par les sillons
creusés par ces députés en
circonscription
[Musique]
Christophe Barthez est élu de l'Aude
à Carcassonne une cérémonie se prépare
quand allez-vous
ce jour-là c'est le cinquième
anniversaire des attentats de Trèbes et
Carcassonne 4 hommes dont le gendarme
Arnaud Beltrame avait trouvé la mort
victime d'un terroriste islamiste
[Musique]
une cérémonie sobre Christophe Barthès
s'occupe dans le protocole la place
normale d'un député de la nation
[Musique]
Monsieur le Préfet
merci d'être là
je suis là depuis longtemps je suis dans
le pays et beaucoup ne font pas la
différence
une heure plus tard autre cérémonie
cette fois devant la mairie de Trèbes
on retrouve les mêmes visages
les mers le préfet
mais cette fois pas de députés
Christophe Barthez n'a pas été convié
par le maire
les seuls élus présents c'était les
trois mers concernés malheureusement par
ce drame la cérémonie officielle était à
Carcassonne ce matin aujourd'hui c'était
un moment pas une cérémonie un moment de
recueillement voulu par les familles
une explication qui arrange bien le
maire
nos Armand hostiles au député RN
fait partie des élus qui s'opposent aux
idées du Front national les chimi
opposerait tout le temps merci
[Musique]
tôt le matin bien avant la cérémonie
comme
merci ciao
prenons acte de sa non invitation
Christophe Barthès avait organisé son
propre hommage
lui aussi
devant la mairie de Trèbes
images à nouveau d'un RN isolé pour le
député aucun doute si le maire de Trèbes
ne l'a pas invité c'est uniquement pour
son étiquette politique
c'est triste que qu'on se servent de
l'événement comme ça pour faire de la
politique politicienne pour mettre les
gens de côté parce que
on a tous une légitimité on n'a pas volé
notre écharpe si on est là c'est parce
que la majorité des gens ce jour-là à
l'élection on pensait que vous serez le
mieux placé pour aller les représenter
donc oui j'en appelle à la démocratie à
l'esprit républicain
cette cérémonie est loin d'être un cas
isolé selon Christophe Barthès dans
l'Aude bastion socialiste depuis des
décennies le RN a bousculé le paysage
politique il a réalisé le Grand Chelem
en remportant les trois circonscriptions
du département
depuis les députés dénoncent tout un
système qui serait mis en place pour
leur nuire
c'est quelque chose qui est insidieux
c'est pas du tout il y a pas de prise de
parole publique pour pour vous attaquer
ça va plutôt être de l'évitement on va
éviter de vous inviter on va essayer de
faire en sorte que vous soyez le moins
visible possible pour que le moment venu
ou prochaine élections on dit bah vous
voyez le député RN on le voit pas il
vient pas il fait pas son boulot j'étais
invité en septembre pour visiter la CAF
coopérative de Limoux et une heure avant
le rendez-vous quand le maire la
présidente du département apprennent que
je suis invité en même temps que ils ont
mis la pression à la cave pour mener
commander et donc la cave a été obligée
de me décommander à ce moment là
dans la commune de par hasard le maire
membre du Parti socialiste accepte de
nous recevoir
Christophe Barthez après son élection
avait proposé de le rencontrer il a
refusé tout net et l'assume des jeunes
qui ont une politique
plus ou moins
totalitaire comme on le dira qui ont une
patronne du parti qui a des accointains
servaient monsieur Poutine vous
comprenez bien que moi ça me convient
pas du tout du tout et je vous reproche
c'est mon droit je fais ce que je veux
j'avais pas envie de le recevoir tout
simplement
chacun est libre après mais je pense
qu'ils ont tort parce que ils vivent
dans un monde parallèle il nous accuse
de choses qui n'existent pas mais
d'abord c'est crispations passent
premièrement donc je dis à notre ami
Barthès c'est à beaucoup d'autres
soyez confiants et accessoirement soyez
patients et puis je vous dis les
Français sont pas d'accord avec ce avec
ces méthodes chacun exerce ses fonctions
de merde de conseil départemental
comme ils l'entend et le Front
républicain il a diverses manifestation
dans celle là
en réalité les élus locaux et les
députés d'autres partis ne sont pas la
première préoccupation du RN dans sa
quête de normalisation
ce qu'il veut convaincre d'abord
ce sont les électeurs
Julien rancoul l'un des députés de
l'Aude est détendu au moment d'arpenter
le marché de Limoux
la colle qu'il reçoit confirme le
message des yeux urnes
on est sérieux et c'est ça
on peut être on peut être d'opposition
mais être sérieux et respecter les
institutions
pays chez nous tout est toujours clivé
tout est toujours
moi je pense qu'il faut un petit peu
bouger
sont plus souples ils sont plus même
s'ils ont des bonnes idées qui irait sur
l'ordi de conduite je trouve que les
mentalités ont changé ils sont moins
agressifs plus constructif depuis un
certain nombre d'années on a changé de
d'objectif on a changé de stratégie et
je pense que c'est bénéfique parce qu'on
attire autour de nous des militants des
cadres qui sont et qui sont vraiment
présentables respectables et qui ont des
idées totalement en républicaine
faut tenir la distance pour le
rassemblement national c'est un travail
long pour sortir des marges du système
pour passer du stade de parti
protestataires de partie de l'excès aux
parties de la mesure aux parties de
gouvernement le rassemblement national
n'est pas au bout de ce processus et
puis il faut aussi que les élus qui sont
maintenant autant de représentants de ce
parti sur le territoire national arrive
à convaincre
au-delà de l'hémicycle c'est 88 députés
donnent au RN une assise territoriale
bien plus consistante il espère
l’élargir encore lors des municipales de
une échéance décisive pour le parti
avant la grande bataille de 2027 son
objectif
ultime
[Musique]